what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime umpror and it was
all a lie all the so-called values of
the hero society
were a lie the symbol of peace itself
was a lie
and it has all been exposed by the new
villain waifu
lady nagant this was one of the most
important chapters in the history of
boku no hero
and the world of mha has now truly
matured
into something dark gritty and real
we need to talk about this dark twist so
let's just get into it
if you enjoyed the boku no hero content
here on the channel you want us to keep
it going just leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps the channel a lot
and of course if you're new to anime
outpour or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet do me a
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram
at anime uproar finally this video will
of course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned
at the end of the previous chapter deku
had just used his newest quirk
fajin to literally smash through a
building and take lady nagan to by
surprise
deku had managed to grab hold of her
other arm the one that doesn't have a
rifle
and lady nagant could tell right away
that something is different
with deku the speed and explosive energy
that he had just demonstrated
is not something that he had used before
and the speed especially seems to have
increased dramatically which lady nagant
noticed right away
deku demands information about all for
one from lady nagant
but she has no intention of giving him
what he wants a high
flying battle ensues and lady nagant
manages to break free from deku's grip
she explains that she was trained to
deal with virtually every combat
situation
by the hero public safety commission and
so she's able to turn the tables on deku
pretty quickly
if you thought that deku was about to
take an easy w after getting the drop on
lady nagant at the end of the previous
chapter you were definitely
off the mark as lady nagant pushes deku
back
he wants to know why she chose to side
with someone like
all for one all for one is a ruthless
villain who is planning
world domination and lady nagant used to
be a hero
so why in the world would she support
all for one
that is when lady nagan says something
incredibly important
she says that some cannot see anything
past
the so-called justice that the hero
society has created
people who follow this idea of justice
blindly
could never understand the truth
meanwhile
deku seems to be experiencing some
problems with his coordination
and it appears that this is a side
effect of fojin that the third user
warned him about
as deku does his best to avoid being hit
by lady nagan's bullets
she proceeds to answer his question from
before
she proclaims that she is tired and that
she has killed enough
to preserve this fake society that
is when we learned the unbelievably dark
truth about the hero
public safety commission and how they
have been really maintaining the hero
society from behind the scenes
from groups of villains plotting
anti-government attacks
to hero groups who are believed to have
associated with villains
it turns out that countless citizens of
the hero society were secretly
assassinated by the public safety
commission
without ever being given the right to a
fair trial and lady nagant was one of
the commission's
assassins while all the famous pro
heroes
worked in the light and made the hero
society look virtuous and wholesome
assassins like lady nagant were working
in the shadows to keep the potential
enemies of the hero society
under control by any means necessary
criminals who were plotting to attack
the hero society were killed before they
ever had a chance to actually commit
the crime and before they had a chance
to have a fair trial
lady nagant literally soaked her hands
in blood
over and over again while obeying the
orders of the public safety commission
while pretending to be a wholesome hero
in public
she was secretly being told to kill
again
and again and again completely outside
the confines of the law
we even get to see a heartbreaking scene
in which a bunch of little kids saw lady
nagant
out on the street and they ran up to her
and wanted to shake her hand
but just as lady nagant was about to
shake the hand of one of the kids
she realized that her hand was still
covered in blood
from a recent state-sanctioned murder
this
incident made her sick these idealistic
little kids
loved her because they thought that she
was this glamorous and morally upright
hero
but in reality she was a cold-blooded
murderer
and all of the murders that she
committed were directly sanctioned by
the rulers of the supposedly noble
hero society that is when lady nagant
realized that it was all
fake it was all alive all this talk
about
justice heroics and the symbol of peace
they were all lies for the hero public
safety commission
this was never really about justice it
was all about gaining
and maintaining power the public safety
commission
talked about the importance of law and
justice in public
but behind the scenes they were working
outside the law in order to keep
themselves in power by any means
necessary they secretly executed fellow
citizens
without any regard for due process or
for the justice system at all
in the end it wasn't the law the justice
system the pro-hero system or even the
symbol of peace itself that kept the
hero society
functioning these were all the things
that the public safety commission
emphasized publicly this is what they
pushed in the media
but in reality the hero society
functioned as well as it did because any
perceived enemies of the system were
secretly assassinated
even if these enemies hadn't yet
committed a crime they were preemptively
eliminated and then the whole thing was
smoothly
covered up this is absolutely
terrifying at one point the chairman of
the public safety commission
ordered lady nagant to kill two fellow
heroes
because they were allegedly provoking
civilians into committing crimes and
then capturing them as criminals in
order to claim rewards
now if they were really doing this it is
obviously a crime
but to straight up execute them and make
them disappear without any trial or due
process
is absolutely outrageous that is not
justice by any stretch of the
imagination
lady nagant actually pushes back on this
she
asks the chairman how killing these
fellow heroes would make society better
and she suggests that doing stuff like
this behind the scenes while portraying
a clean and pure image to the public
is basically brainwashing the chairman
simply says that doing what she does
is necessary in order to maintain the
hope that the more
public pro heroes have instilled in the
public
and he then straight up threatens her
implying that if she refuses to do this
and tries to resign then the commission
will make
her disappear this definitely makes
sense from their perspective because she
clearly knows
way too much but for lady nagant this
really drives home the true
terrifying nature of the hero society
lady nagant then tells the chairman that
she respects him
before she goes on to shoot him and
presumably kill him
when deku hears this he realizes that
the public
was lied to the death of the chairman
was reported completely differently
in the media because the public safety
commission insisted on protecting their
false public image and so they didn't
want anyone to know that there were
internal disputes happening within the
commission
itself lady nagant then explains that
the hero society is actually weak and
fragile
and it lures in idealistic kids with
false promises of a bright future
and then it turns them into monsters
lady nagan herself
was taken in by the public safety
commission when she was just a child
and she was then lied to and brainwashed
until she became the commission's
personal killing machine compared to
that
even a future where all for one was in
complete control
would be more honest because at least
then everyone would know
where they stand all for one is a
villain and he wants power
but at least he's honest about it the
current rulers of the pro-hero society
are also villains who operate outside
the law and play
judge jury and executioner wherever they
see fit but
they use lies and propaganda to present
themselves as
just and pure wow this is an absolutely
massive revelation before lady nagan's
backstory
we knew that hawks was taken in by the
public safety commission as a child
and we knew that they made him do some
highly questionable things
for instance they ordered him to
infiltrate the league of villains
essentially forcing him to live a
dangerous double life
and they also ordered him to straight up
kill villains like twice
if he found himself in a situation where
that was the best course of action
but while all of this wasn't exactly
ethical it was still understandable from
a law enforcement perspective
police agents do go undercover and
sometimes they do kill criminals
if those criminals are perceived to be
an imminent threat to innocent people
but killing people before they even
committed a crime
or killing pro heroes because they are
suspected of shady dealings without any
due process
is completely out of the realm of
acceptability
this is a flagrant abuse of power and if
this is what the pro hero safety
commission does
then there is no difference between them
and the villains
they themselves are the villains and
lady nagant was able to see that
and she simply couldn't take it anymore
wow
i knew that she was going to have an
interesting backstory but this was just
heartbreaking and amazing back on the
battlefield
deku suddenly uses black whip to try to
get the upper hand
in the fight against lady nagant as she
tries to adjust to yet another
quirk in deku's arsenal deku confirms
that he finally understands that the
world is not
black and white it is all just shades of
grey
the world is full of anger and anxiety
and the hero society itself has
many skeletons in their closet skeletons
that in many cases went on to become the
villains that we know today
but deku still won't give up on his
ideals
clearly he is no longer completely
idealistic about pro heroes
and the hero society he knows that the
world is not
black and white nevertheless he is still
holding out hope that he can help those
like shigaraki who were betrayed
by the hero society he still believes
that everyone
can be saved as they continue to fight
lady nagant realizes that deku is
extremely versatile
even in the air and he now seems to be
able to predict
and avoid her projectiles as a result
she decides to increase his mental
burden and in the next few panels
we see overhaul calling out to lady
nagant and telling her that he wants to
get
back to his boss man this guy really
simps
for his boss he's probably up there on
the roof crying and singing the lyrics
to the ghost of you
while thinking about his boss deku is
shocked to see overhaul
aka chisaki again like this completely
out of nowhere and
as deku's attention is drawn in the
direction of overhaul
lady nagant seems to be preparing to
make her move
and that is how this excellent and
extremely significant
chapter ends this was an absolutely
huge reveal and i cannot overstate the
importance
of this chapter up to this point we've
seen that the world of mha has been
getting progressively darker and
grittier but what we saw in this chapter
was closer to something you would see in
the boys than something you would see in
a traditional superhero story
it's not just the villains who are doing
genuinely terrible things
anymore the very heart of the hero
society
the top leadership of the hero public
safety commission
are actual villains themselves i mean
think about it
they are recruiting young and
impressionable children and then
brainwashing them into becoming ruthless
killers these killers are then ordered
to make potential
enemies of the commission disappear
without a trial
or due process it's the kind of thing
you'd expect to happen in the most
brutal authoritarian dictatorships
and yet it's happening in the supposedly
noble and virtuous
hero society this is a very dark turn
that i wasn't necessarily expecting
at least not so suddenly but at the same
time i absolutely
loved it deku will now be forced to
confront his idealism head on
and he will have to come to terms with
the cruel reality of the hero society
and this chapter really made me feel for
lady nagant
can you blame her for becoming a villain
after everything that was done to her
she was recruited at a very young and
vulnerable age
and she was manipulated into being an
assassin for the government
she was ordered to do terrible and
clearly illegal things
and if she refused to do something it
was implied that she herself would be
the next one to disappear
to her credit at one point she decided
that enough
is enough that scene with the children
and the blood on her hands was
especially
heartbreaking and it showcased so
perfectly the tension between the false
public image of the hero society
and the cruel reality of what was
happening behind the scenes
instead of continuing to be controlled
and manipulated by the commission
chairman lady nagant made him pay for
his crimes
and then she chose her own path now of
course
serving all for one may not be the
wisest path to follow
but it's already pretty clear that lady
nagant doesn't feel any loyalty to all
for one
it is quite possible that she will turn
against him at some point
in the future lady nagant clearly does
have a moral compass despite her dark
past and i don't really think that all
for one does have a moral compass at all
so i think that the two of them are
bound to clash eventually definitely let
me know what you guys think
did you love this chapter as much as i
did and what did you think about this
crazy reveal surrounding the hero public
safety commission
how do you think that deku and the other
pro heroes are going to handle this
explosive information deco especially is
gonna have to come to terms with the
fact that this hero society that he
idolized for so long
was a big giant lie on top of that
do you think that sometime in the future
lady nagant might switch sides and
turn on all for one let me know down
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content here on
the channel
please leave a like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and red
haired raven
these guys are absolute mad lads and
disciples
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
algital dr cortman the toasted chi ry
carlo
slickback emperor otaku spidey life
chanel tungsten tarquez
baked buddhist and cody hebert finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
very gucci alicia octor bonnie park
sinokami
and water 10 no ted isparky65 joanne
garcia
fat boy games metal mama corey mcgowan
deadly saint soul ray slice and dice and
pillow
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you